welcome to the Stanford center for
professional development a unit of
Stanford University's School of
Engineering one of the top-rated schools
in the world we're pleased that you'd
like to learn more about the graduate
level courses and programs for working
professionals that we offer online and
at Stanford since its founding in 1891
Stanford University has had a philosophy
that its students should gain an
education that will make them useful
citizens connections to industry are
grounded in the seminal research
conducted by Stanford faculty senior
researchers and students the foundation
for the Stanford center for professional
development goes back more than 50 years
in his role to extend the research and
teaching of Stanford faculty through
courses and programs for engineers
technology professionals managers and
executives a breakthrough outcomes of
these research has led to the transfer
of Technology and to the families of
more than 5,000 companies each year
thousands of professionals continue
their education through our Center some
are updating their skills while others
are responding to change all are looking
to grow and adapt to new opportunities
what are your goals alumni and students
frequently cite the extraordinary
support and teaching strengths of
faculty many of whom have received the
highest honors in their fields as the
core of the Stanford experience Stanford
University promotes and encourages
interdisciplinary work believing that
true innovation occurs that intellectual
intersections and through group
collaboration networking and mentorship
students to take courses to the Stanford
center for professional development are
part of the university setting that
draws on the research from the School of
Engineering as well as the schools of
medicine law business and humanities and
Sciences on demand 24 hours a day seven
days a week
our portfolio is comprised of two types
of courses graduate and professional
graduate courses are the same as those
taught on campus and they carry academic
credit which will appear on a Stanford
transcript the successful completion of
three to five courses in an area of
study may lead to one or more than 25
graduate certificates qualified
individuals who apply and are admitted
may pursue a Masters of Science degree
on a part-time basis professional
courses and programs are developed and
delivered under the leadership of a
Stanford faculty member professional
certificate programs such as Stanford
advance project management and strategic
decisions and risk management qualify
for professional development units many
students have completed both graduate
and professional certificate programs
you can read about some of them in the
student spotlight section of our website
our courses are drawn from the various
engineering departments as well as the
schools of medicine and science and the
humanities many students enroll in
courses from the department of
management science and engineering whose
vision is to work at the interface of
engineering business and public policy
since its founding
Stanford University has been a pioneer
in cross-disciplinary collaboration
among faculty students and researchers
Stanford has seven schools on one campus
and all of them possess exceptional
breadth and depth of excellence an
example of multidisciplinary
collaboration is the graduate
certificate in product creation and
innovative manufacturing created at the
intersection of mechanical engineering
chemical engineering and management
science for those who aspire to a
master's degree this slide illustrates a
recommended path to enroll in individual
courses and perhaps earn a graduate
certificate while preparing your
application for the master's program up
to 18 years of credit earned may be
applied towards her degree if you are
admitted into a master's program if you
already have all of the degrees you need
a graduate certificate is a great way to
keep your skills and knowledge current
in your field graduate courses may be
taken for credit or audited an employer
may become a member of the Stanford
center for professional development
making it possible for employees to
receive preferential tuition rates
preferential tuition is also extended to
members and veterans of the US Armed
Forces every unit for which credit is
given represents one hour of class time
plus approximately two additional hours
of work per week for the average student
there for a three unit course requires a
minimum time commitment of nine hours
per week
auditing provides access to online
lectures only students submitted to the
part-time masters program need to be
employed by a company member of the
Stanford center for professional
development or be an active member of
the US Armed Forces 23 master's degree
depths may be completed entirely online
some degree depths requires some
attendance at courses on campus while
other depths may be completed entirely
at Stanford in all cases part-time
masters students have access to campus
libraries labs and resources the same as
full-time residential students part-time
masters degree students come to campus
for graduation and to celebrate their
achievement with family and friends they
become part of the global community of
Stanford alumni the only difference
between full-time and part-time pursuit
of a master's degree is that part-time
takes longer learning today applied
tomorrow is the mission of our portfolio
of professional courses and programs
these short intensive courses help you
develop skills in an innovation
decision-making strategy execution and
technology leadership courses are
offered online at Stanford and can be
delivered to a group at your workplace
designed for experienced project
managers the Stanford advanced project
management curriculum introduces
advanced tools and techniques to
strategically execute projects
and portfolios close to 4,000
participants have earned the credential
of Stanford certified project manager
since the inception of the program in
1999 online courses are self-paced and
available anytime participants may come
to campus to engage with faculty and
network with peers courses may be taken
in any order and in any method of
instruction or in combination what makes
a good decision does a bad outcome mean
it was a bad decision the strategic
decision in risk management professional
certificate derives from the research
and teachings of Stanford professor
Ronald Howard considered by me to be the
father of decision analysis now that
you've heard all about what Stanford has
to offer you're probably wondering what
to do next
exploit our website is the best way to
get started from our homepage at CPD da
stanford.edu
you can search our entire course
portfolio preview courses contact course
advisors and access free online videos
you can also join the Stanford community
by creating a free my Stanford
connection account this account will
enable you to register for free live
webinars and lectures apply for and
enrolled in courses access your student
records and manage all aspects of your
student profile once you have set up
this account you may log in at any time
from the tab at the top right of the
home page one of the most valuable
benefits of having a my Stanford
connection account is real access to
free online content register for live or
virtual meetings with Stanford faculty
industry experts and senior researchers
as they go beyond the course curriculum
to address emerging topics watch
previously recorded webinars on our
website or on our YouTube channel
Stanford online we also offer a popular
Stanford engineering seminars online
while we hope we have answered most of
your questions doing this presentation
we know you will probably have more
questions as you explore our offerings
in more depth one of the most frequently
asked questions we receive is whether
academic units earned under the non
degree option can be applied towards a
degree yes up to eighteen units may be
applied towards a degree program once
you have been accepted as a master's
degree candidate you may also be
wondering how exams are administered to
distant students for graduate courses
within the first three weeks of classes
you will be required to identify someone
to be your exam monitor this could be
your manager
Human Resources or education manager an
exam that you are required to take will
be sent to the exam monitor with
instructions as to when the exam is to
be administered and how and when the
completed exam is to be returned most
online professional courses include an
online exam we are happy to answer any
questions you may have our student and
client services team is here to assist
you with questions about courses and
programs applications enrollment
homework and exams please don't hesitate
to contact us via phone at six five zero
seven two five three zero one six four
email at SCPD - customer service one
word at stanford.edu again email SCPD -
customer service at stanford.edu
last but not least we have many ways you
can connect with us and more importantly
of the members of our staff or community
you can find us on Facebook LinkedIn and
Google+ by searching for Stanford center
for professional development and on
Twitter at Stanford online thank you for
your interest in Stanford center for
professional development we look forward
to helping you meet your education and
career goals